COVID-19 has come through and completely decimated and put on pause the bar and restaurant industry.
We got about 8 million people out of work, and bar and restaurant owners struggling to come up with new ways
to possibly stay in business.
I'm Jacob Greer I work in the bar and hospitality business, I'm also a freelance writer,
I write for Reason as well as other public policy outlets.
Talking to other people in the industry, talking to bartenders they want two things.
One they want to go back to work, but they also want to stay safe,
and it's really hard to do both at the same time if the only option is for people to come into a bar or restaurant
and to gather inside.
We're seeing it's just a recipe for spreading the virus so we don't want to end up in a cycle of reopening and
then reclosing constantly, which we're seeing right now.
We'd like to find something that's more stable.
Talking to people in my industry the number one item on their wish list is to be free to sell cocktails to go.
They want to be able to package a drink up to go alongside their food or even by itself,
for a customer to take home and drink.
The other quick ideas would be to expand outdoor spaces for drinking which could be through
closing sidewalks, putting out tables, even closing down entire streets and creating public social plazas,
or if you want to go all the way they're eliminating open container laws entirely, so it's no longer a crime
to have a drink outside.
So in much of the world, especially in Asia and other parts of Europe,
it's not against the law it's not a crime to be outside drinking,
and that was the case in the United States as well.
For most of our history it was not a crime simply to drink in public it was a crime to be drunk in public,
and that's a key distinction.
In the 1970's there became this push to make the law less discretionary, more objective,
and the way they did that was to say the act of drinking itself is now the crime,
and that highly constrained where people could drink.
When we think of open containers we think of party atmospheres like Las Vegas,
or Bourbon Street in New Orleans, but there's also a lot more relaxed places
that have varying degrees of open container permission,
like say Hood River in Oregon or Sonoma in California, it doesn't have to be a party atmosphere,
especially if you don't force everyone into one narrow space.
It could be just allowing people to have a drink in the park,
to have a picnic to walk around their neighborhood with a drink in hand.
Prohibition happened in 1920 and contrary to popular image of the fun speakeasy with great cocktails,
what actually happened was we destroyed our cocktail culture in the United States through that period,
and we didn't really recover until the early 2000s, up until now and all of this has been hugely hit by the shutdown.
Right now I view these laws about allowing us to do cocktails to go and expanding outdoor spaces
as much about damage control as anything else,
and to prevent this from being completely erased and giving it some chance to survive.